you had david goggins in the lab to
study him for fear what did you learn
from looking at that guy yeah david's
david's great i always chuckle with
david because you know the one thing
about david is what you see on social
media is actually
what you get when you interact with
david we worked long hours one day and i
was everyone was ready to tap out this
was a bunch of people in uh silicon
valley for a day you know doing some
workshop type thing and he just he was
changing into his running shorts midway
he was going to run to the airport and
he ran to the airport as far as i know i
get his flight i believe so you know
but there was this moment of should we
continue should we take a break and he
was like no let's keep going keep going
um everything you see and read and hear
about david is exactly how he shows up
it's really wonderful um he came to the
lab and he did you know we have a
virtual version of the shark thing
um which of course is not the same as
the real experience but for people who
are afraid of sharks it's quite scary
for them and allows us to study fear
david was he's very afraid of sharks
which was sort of uh amusing to me given
that as a seal he had to spend a lot of
time in the water but he was first one
in wanted to do the vr talked about how
he didn't like it but um but that's why
he did it you know constant uh testing
himself in fact i think even though
david's quite successful i think and has
many many options of how to spend his
time i believe this is correct i think
right now he's doing fire jumping he's
fighting fires in the wilderness by zip
lining in or fast lining in or jumping
out of planes so he's constantly pushing
that uh that friction lever to create
or build or
further build this thing about leaning
into friction and this is a term that
isn't really scientific but that i
decided to coin because this idea of
limbic friction that when we're very
tired and we need to be in action or
when we're very stressed and we need to
perform in a more calm and controlled
way there's friction on both sides
getting out of bed when we're exhausted
hard
very hard often
leaning into action in a calm and
deliberate way when we're freaking out
like going to give a public lecture if
one has fear of public speaking also
hard so this limbic friction and david
just seems to seek what i call limbic
friction in every domain of life is that
like exposure therapy for limbic
friction then essentially yeah i mean
what you're training and improving when
you're getting better at dealing with
stress
is this ability to tolerate high amounts
of adrenaline in your body and to think
clearly and function well i mean
adrenaline is epinephrine and just a
little bit of physiology it's released
from the adrenals obviously above the
kidneys that gets your body organs
amped up and energized
it can't cross the so-called blood-brain
barrier you have a high restriction
fence that we call the blood-brain
barrier around the brain
keep bad molecules out
adrenaline therefore is released also
within the brain from a little cluster
of neurons called locus ceruleus the
name doesn't matter so when you are
stressed
your brain and your body both wake up
and that adrenaline
hijacks certain systems narrows your
visual focus etc etc if you look at
almost all stress inoculation
protocols
cold water ice bath cold shower cyclic
hyperventilation
those all do the same thing they
generate a lot of adrenaline release in
the brain and a lot of adrenaline
release in the body
but it's different if those if the
adrenaline in the brain and body is
evoked by you that you did it because
under conditions under which you did the
ice bath deliberately and now you're
wide awake and really really alert
there's this feeling that you have
options it wasn't done to you but you
can train up an ability to for instance
think
clearly and calmly um maybe even do some
simple math problems in your head or
maybe try and relax while there's all
this adrenaline in your system and that
carries over so that when you you know
we've all done it you're driving along
the person in front of you stop short
and you're almost in the accident right
there's that moment where you could
panic or that moment where you could you
know road rage or that moment where you
could freak out but if you are familiar
with the feeling of adrenaline in your
brain and body you navigate that in a in
a calmer way how well because adrenaline
is generic there's no adrenaline for the
car crash adrenaline for the heights
adrenaline for the
the uh the relationship situation it's
all the same so we can get better we can
raise our stress threshold as i like to
refer to it and that can be done through
cold water or cyclic hyperventilation
ideally not at the same time but cold
water you know is a universal stimulus
for creating adrenaline release and
there's a big range of cold not infinite
but a big range of cold
in which you can generate adrenaline
without harming your tissue whereas with
heat you get into a very hot environment
or very low oxygen environment you'll
also get a lot of adrenaline but you can
also suffocate and burn yourself so this
is why cold is used in navy seal
screening and training and this is why i
think so many people really like the ice
bath in cold showers has a bunch of
other positive effects but it is a great
trigger for adrenaline
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you